Hallo, guten Tag, mein Name ist Tekrem Özübalı.
Ich bin auf der Station Arslan Arstethik.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen heute ein Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich.
Zunächst benötige ich ein paar persönliche Daten, dann können wir weiterführen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Karl Schulte.
Karl Schulte.
Können Sie bitte Ihr Vornamen und Nachnamen langsam buchstabieren?
Ja, der Vornamen ist beidem eigentlich kurz.
K-A-R-L. Karl, ein Männername.
Und Schulte, S-C-H-U-L-T-E.
T-E, Karl Schulte.
Herr Schulte.
Okay, Herr Schulte, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 750.
57, ja.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren, Herr Schulte?
Am 4.12.68.
4.12.1968.
68, okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,77.
77 und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege so 79 Kilo.
79 Kilo, vielen Dank für die Information.
79, ne?
79.
Ja, nicht 70.
Vielen Dank.
Herr Schulte, was für eine Saison ist das?
Ich habe schon seit längerer Zeit, eigentlich ja, schon seit Monaten,
habe ich immer mal so Schmerzen, wenn ich mich ein bisschen anstrengen.
Wenn ich treppenlaufe, dann tut es mir hier oben so in der Brust direkt unterhalb vom Hals weh.
Und heute Morgen, da war das ganz komisch.
Und das waren richtig heftige Schmerzen.
Und da habe ich mich aber überhaupt nicht angestrengt.
Ich habe einfach nur in Ruhe bei meinem Frühstück gesessen.
Und mit einem mal fängt das an.
Und ich hatte solch einen Druck.
Und habe auch wirklich Angst bekommen.
Und mit einem mal war mir schlecht.
Und ich hatte das Gefühl, mir läuft der Schweiß runter.
Es war ganz furchtbar.
Und die Schmerzen waren richtig, richtig stark.
Und ja, ich hatte das Gefühl, mein Herz klopft mir irgendwie bis zum Hals.
Und dann habe ich mich im Moment hingesetzt, dann ist es auch wieder weggegangen.
Und nach einer Weile, aber ich hatte das Gefühl, das dauert lange.
Und ich habe dann überlegt, rufst du jetzt den Notruf an?
Und als es dann aber besser ging, habe ich dann gesagt, okay, ich erhole mich jetzt erst mal.
Und dann habe ich aber gedacht, ich muss heute doch noch hier in die Klinik kommen.
Ja, das war schon so, dass mir das wirklich Angst gemacht hat, gebe ich zu.
Ich verstehe. Und Herr Schulta, ist das das erste Mal aufgetreten oder haben Sie dafür eine Schübischwerden?
Ja, also wie gesagt, ich habe das schon in den letzten Monaten, wenn ich mich sehr angestrengt habe,
wenn ich also schnell eine Treppe hochgelaufen bin, oder wenn ich eine schwere Tasche getragen habe
und da also zügig gelaufen bin, da kannte ich das schon, dass ich dann mal merkte,
so jetzt musst du mal langsam machen, so, aber dass ich solche Schmerzen und auch solche Angstzustände habe,
das habe ich so noch nicht erlebt.
Ja, okay, okay, ich verstehe. Okay.
Herr Schulta, da ein Notverdacht besteht, deswegen muss das Aufnahmegespräch kurz unterbrechen.
Und dann ich werde einen EKG schreiben, wenn alles normal ist, können wir weiterführen.
Okay, ja, das kann ich gut verstehen.
Okay, ich werde ein wenig Blut abnehmen und einen EKG durchführen, dann können wir weiterführen.
Okay, können wir weiterführen?
Ja.
Okay. Vor einem Monat hatten Sie endliche Beschwerden?
Ja, eigentlich schon länger, also das geht eigentlich schon,
eigentlich geht das schon in die letzten drei Monate so, ja, aber das war nie so schlimm,
das war immer nur, wenn ich mich wirklich stark angestrengt habe, ja, du musst halt ein bisschen langsam machen,
aber sowas, das war heute Morgen schon sehr unangenehm.
Okay, waren Sie deswegen bei Ihrem Hausarzt oder einer Kardiologin besucht, oder?
Na ja, damals war ich schon mal bei meinem Arzt und da war aber nie irgendwas,
ja, aber das war mir jetzt doch ein bisschen zu viel.
Okay, könnten Sie bitte genau die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Wie ist das?
Ja, so ein ganz dumpfer Druck, wirklich, also hier so hinter dem Brustbein einfach, ne?
Hinterbrustbein, hinterbrustbein, Herr Schulter, wie viele Treppen können Sie ohne Belastung hochgehen?
Ja, wenn ich mir Zeit lasse, so zwei Treppen, eine Etage schaffe ich,
aber so ab zwei Etagen, dann muss ich schon ein bisschen pusten, ja.
Okay, machst du mal zwei Etage.
In der Nacht, oder, kannst du flach liegen, oder?
Nee, das mag ich eigentlich schon ziemlich lange nicht.
Ich hab mein Bett so ein bisschen hochgestellt.
Haben Sie geschwollenen, geröteten oder überwärmten Beinen bemerkt?
Jetzt, bei der Hitze, sind die Beine schon mal ein bisschen geschwollen,
dann hab ich so Schnürren da von den Socken, da wo das Sockenbündchen ist,
aber das ist eigentlich jetzt nur, wenn es so extrem heiß ist, sonst eigentlich nicht.
Haben Sie im Moment Atemnoten-Engelgefühl?
Nein, das ist zum Glück alles wieder weg, aber der Schreck sitzt mir natürlich noch in den Knochen.
Zum Beispiel Herzrassen oder Atemnot, wie ein Atakenartikel angedauert.
Boah, es kommt einem ja wie eine Ewigkeit vor, aber wahrscheinlich waren das zehn Minuten oder so.
Der Regen, haben Sie einen Medikament eingenommen, oder?
Nee, ich hab jetzt gar nichts eingenommen.
Ich nehme ja immer nur meine Blutdruck-Tabletten, aber sonst nehme ich nichts.
Strahlende Schmerzen, irgendwo hinaus in den Rücken, linke Arme?
Nee, eigentlich das ist nur hier so hinter der Brust, also da, aber das strahlt nicht aus weiter.
Zum Beispiel meine ich Oberbauch, oder?
Nein, da ist nichts.
Nur hinter der Brust, okay.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen versteckt?
Zum Beispiel vorne beugen oder etwas lindern, zum Beispiel hinlegen oder in Ruhe?
Als ich mich dann hingelegt habe, hatte ich das Gefühl, dass es besser ist.
Aber natürlich mit dem Oberkörper ein bisschen hoch, ne?
Haben Sie Fieber, Herr Schulte?
Ich fühle mich nicht fiebrig, also ich habe aber auch ehrlich gesagt nicht gemessen.
Fühlen Sie Fieber?
Nein, ich fühle mich nicht fiebrig.
Ja, nee, okay.
Haben Sie Schüttelfrost?
Sie haben schon gesagt, ein Kaltschweiß?
Haben Sie Kopfschmerzen oder haben Sie schon einmal Schwindelfen?
Nee, eigentlich vom Kopf her habe ich da nichts gemerkt, nee.
Zum Beispiel schon einmal haben Sie Bewusstsein verloren, oder?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste, nee, nee, also Bewusstsein habe ich noch nicht verloren, nee.
Und Atemnot, Engelgefühl, Marshmallow, Arthenathetik, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nee, Gott sei Dank noch nicht.
In der Nacht schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, also wenn ich gut liege geht es eigentlich, aber ich habe tatsächlich in letzter Zeit manchmal so Probleme beim Einschlafen, dass ich so denke, oh hoffentlich ist jetzt nichts, ja, also hoffentlich drückt es nicht wieder so, das macht mir dann so ein bisschen Angst, ne?
Wie ist Ihr Appetit, Herr Schutter?
Normalerweise ist er eigentlich, doch, würde ich schon sagen, der ist gut.
Heute hat es mir jetzt nicht so geschmeckt, da war ich irgendwie so ein bisschen unruhig und hatte das Gefühl, ich habe jetzt keinen dollen Appetit, aber das schadet, wenn es so warm ist, hat man ja auch nicht so viel Hunger.
Ja, ich verstehe. Und erfüllen Sie sich durstig, oder?
Durstig, also ja, ich trinke halt schon gut eigentlich, gerade wenn es so warm ist, ja, und habe immer die Wasserflasche dabei.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Ungewohnt ab- oder zugenommen?
Also ist mir nicht aufgefallen, ich wiege mich natürlich jetzt nicht jeden Tag, aber eigentlich ist mein Gewicht seit Jahren stabil.
Messen Sie ja Blutdruck regelmäßig, oder?
Ja, das mache ich eigentlich nur beim Hausarzt. Ich weiß gar nicht, wir haben zwar so ein Gerät irgendwo im Haus, das habe ich dann mal genutzt, als wir am Anfang, als man das festgestellt hat, aber das mache ich jetzt nicht jeden Tag.
Okay, okay, ich verstehe. Herr Schutter, haben Sie noch irgendwelche klinische Erklankungen bisher?
Ich habe sonst nie irgendwas gehabt.
Zum Beispiel Blutzucker oder Schmuckdruck oder...
Würden Sie schon mal operiert?
Na ja, als Kind habe ich die Mandeln rausbekommen und dann, ja, als junger Erwachsener habe ich mit 18 den Blinddarm noch rausbekommen.
Blinddarm? Okay, Blinddarm. Und Mandelanfernung? Wann war?
Oh, das war vor der Grundschule, also so mit sechs ungefähr.
Sechs ungefähr? Und Blinddarm-Einfernung?
Da war ich 18.
18, okay.
Beide waren komplikationlos, oder?
Ja, als Kind hat man ja keine Komplikation, das ist alles knapp gelaufen.
Es sind ja auch kleine Eingriffe gewesen, das hat man ja ständig gemacht.
Okay. Und Herr Schutter, haben Sie noch Gegner, was? Allergie?
Ja, es gibt eine Allergie gegen so Metall, gegen nickelhaltiges Metall, da muss ich aufpassen.
Da habe ich so eine Kontakteallergie bei Werkzeug oder bei so Geräten, die so Nickel in der Legierung haben.
Das kann ich nicht vertragen, da kriege ich so rote Bläschen an der Haut, wenn ich da Kontakt habe.
Rote Ausschlag, ja gehen Sie auf mit rote Ausschlag, okay.
Ich habe das notiert und okay.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland oder haben Sie in letzter Zeit gereist?
Nein, wir haben einmal eine Klassenfahrt in die Wiedereinheit gemacht, aber das war ja nur zwei Tage oder so, aber eine exotische Reise habe ich nicht gemacht.
Sind Sie vorgeimpft?
Ich bin geimpft, ja natürlich, klar.
Gegen Covid, da bin ich geimpft, ja.
Und also Grippeimpfung mache ich eigentlich auch alle Jahre, ja.
Herr Schutter, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf irgendwelche Medikamente ein oder?
Ja, ich habe ja von meinem Hausarzt diese Blutdruckmedikamente bekommen.
Da nehme ich Nebivolol morgens und Walzakor nehme ich auch morgens.
Nebivolol und Walzakor, wie viel Milligramm?
Nebivolol ist 5 und Walzakor 80.
Walzakor 80, beide sind morgens.
Nee, sonst nehme ich nichts.
Okay, was noch?
Sonst nehme ich nichts.
Okay, sonst nehmen Sie nichts.
Herr Schutter, rauchen Sie?
Eigentlich kann man das nicht rauchen nennen.
Also, ja in den Schulen ist ja heutzutage generell Rauchverbot.
Also dann rauche ich am Nachmittag und am Abend mal so, ja, so vielleicht 3, 4 Zigaretten am Tag.
Ich habe also nie, nie richtig viel geraucht.
Das ist mehr so, ja, Gesellschaft.
Wie lange?
Was wie lange?
In den Schuljahren, wenn ich richtig verstanden habe.
Sie haben in den Schülern.
Ich arbeite als Lehrer.
Ich arbeite als Lehrer, deswegen muss ich immer noch zur Schule gehen, auch in meinem Alter, ja.
Und also früher durfte man ja in den Schulen auch noch rauchen, aber das ist ja jetzt schon lange verboten.
Und es gibt auch keine Raucherzimmer oder sowas.
Und deswegen wird in der Schule eigentlich gar nicht mehr geraucht.
Aber jetzt rauche ich eben noch meine 3, 4 Zigaretten am Nachmittag.
Oder am Abend, je nachdem, ja.
Ok, am Nachmittag 3, 4 Zigaretten.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also bei solchen Wetter wie jetzt, dann trinke ich gerne abends mal eine Flasche Bier oder auch zwei.
Und wenn es was zu feiern gibt, dann trinken wir auch gerne mal ein schönes Glas Wein zum Essen, ja.
Aber jetzt also längst nicht jeden Abend, ne?
Ja, ok, super.
Und bitte nehmen Sie nicht diese Frage persönlich.
Haben Sie schon einmal Drogen konsumiert oder?
Ich? Nee, nee, nee. Also mit Drogen, das überlasse ich anderen Leuten, ja.
Ja, super, ok.
Herr Schulter, sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Na ja, also, die sind ja nun auch schon ganz schön alt, ne?
Also meine Mutter, die hatte eine Bypass-Operation und das ist irgendwie gar nicht gut gelaufen.
Und danach ging es ja also sehr, sehr schlecht.
Und mein Vater hatte tatsächlich auch einen Herzinfarkt.
Aber er hat sich da eigentlich ganz gut erholt.
Also dafür, dass die beide schon so alt sind, haben die sich eigentlich ganz gut gehalten, ja.
Wie alt ist er?
Na ja, also die sind jetzt beide weit über 80, ja.
Über 80, ok.
Ihre Mutter unter Kontrolle, oder?
Ja, ja, die sind beide regelmäßig in ärztlicher Kontrolle.
Ok, über 80, beide.
Haben Sie Geschwister, Herr Schulter?
Nee, ich war Einzelkind.
Einzelkind, ok.
Sie sind Lehrer?
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Eine Tochter haben wir, aber die ist schon erwachsen, die ist schon aus dem Haus.
Die lebt nicht mehr mit uns zusammen.
Ja, ok.
Ihre Tochter ist gesund?
Die ist gesund, ja.
Also erwachsen, aber jung, ne?
Ja, natürlich.
Ok.
Leiden Sie unter Stress bei der Arbeit, oder?
Ja, das kann man wohl nicht leugnen, ja.
Das gibt immer wieder Überraschungen.
Man kann nie sicher sein, dass alles so funktioniert, wie man sich das vorgestellt hat.
Ja, also da haben wir schon viel Stress, ja.
Herr Schulter, haben Sie Husten?
Ob ich Husten habe?
Nein, nicht.
Ok.
Herr Schulter, ich habe mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Naja, also ich wüsste schon jetzt, was kann dahinter stecken.
Und ja, vor allem, wie kann ich das verhindern, dass es wieder solche Attacken gibt?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich habe einen Verdacht auf Occius-Coronavirus-Syndrom.
Das bleibt aber nur eine Vermutung.
Um das zu bestätigen, können wir die Untersuchungen durchführen.
Zuerst werde ich sie körperlich untersuchen.
Und ja, wenn es nötig ist, weiter Blut abnehmen.
Aber Sie haben ja eben auch schon Blut abgenommen, ne?
Ja, das haben wir schon gemacht.
Wenn wir weitere Labore untersuchen brauchen, können wir wieder Blut abnehmen.
Vielleicht eine Echokardiographie durchführen.
Und eine Kardiologische Konzil.
Ah, ja, okay, das sind die Fachleute.
Ich kann Ihnen bald Ihre Ergebnisse vorlegen.
Ich informiere Sie.
Okay, gut, danke.
Frau Schulter, darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Natürlich, ich bin Herr Schulter.
Herr Schulter.
Entschuldigen, Herr Schulter.
Sind Ihre Blutdruck gut eingestellt?
Haben Sie Ihre Blutdruck regelmäßig eingestellt?
Hat er noch gerade gefragt, ja.
Also ich messe nicht regelmäßig, aber der Haushalt ist immer zufrieden.
Herr Schulter, ist Ihnen übel? Haben Sie erbrochen?
Erbrochen habe ich nicht, aber übel war mir.
Ja, aber jetzt nicht mehr.
Heute Vormittag, da habe ich starke Übelkeit gehabt, ja.
Und was ist denn passiert heute?
Hat es irgendwelche wichtigste emotionelle Belastung bei Ihnen?
Ich kann mir das gar nicht erklären.
Das kam aus heiterem Himmel.
Deswegen hat es mir eigentlich auch so Angst gemacht.
Weil bei den anderen Malen, da wusste ich,
ja, jetzt bist du einfach, da hast du dich zu sehr angestrengt.
Und jetzt war es so, dass das so aus der Ruhe raus,
und das hat mich halt schon sehr erschreckt.
Haben Sie Sortbrünen oder Sauers ausgetauschen?
Nee, das habe ich zum Glück nicht.
Und bisher keine Magenbeschwerden bei Ihnen?
Nee, also Magen, also glaube ich habe ich nichts, nee.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Schulter, seit wann bei Ihnen eine Bluthochdruckerkrankung besteht?
Seit 10 Jahren, genau.
Seit wann brauchen Sie täglich 4,50 Euro?
Seit 35 Jahren.
35 Jahre, danke.
Die Essgewohnheiten.
Ja, genau.
Ist das so viel Fleisch und Fett und heftiges Essen?
Nein, eigentlich mag ich nicht gerne fettiges Essen.
Aber ich esse ausgesprochen gerne, das gebe ich zu.
Ja, es schmeckt mir gut, weil meine Frau sehr gut kocht.
Und ich koche manchmal auch.
Und wenn wir mal auswärts essen, dann lasse ich eigentlich auch nicht viel auf dem Teller übrig, ehrlich gesagt.
Und essen Sie auch salzig?
Salzig?
Ich glaube nicht übermäßig, aber ein bisschen nachsalzen, hin und wieder mache ich das schon.
Danke.
Und eine Kollegin möchte wissen, wie stark war die Schmerzintensität?
Schmerzintensität, da habe ich so mit einem halben Auge gesehen.
Gebt ihr mit 8 von 10 an?
Hallo, guten Tag, Frau Oberarztin.
Ich habe in der Notaufnahme einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Möchte ich Ihnen ihn vorstellen.
Ja, wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Okay, vielen Dank.
Und Karl Schulter.
Karl Schulter ist 57 Jahre alt und geboren am 4.12.1968.
Und Herr Schulter 1,77 Meter groß und 79 Kilo wiegt.
Und Herr Schulter stellt sich heute bei uns seit heute Morgen plötzlich aufgetretenen Hinterbrustschmerzen vor.
Laut Angaben des Patienten, die Schmerzen sind beim Treppenhochgehen plötzlich aufgetreten.
Er erwähnte, dass die Schmerzen sehr heftig und begleitend sind zu Tod, Angst und Kaltschweiß.
Außerdem berichtet er, dass die Schmerzen, dass die Beschwerden ca. 3 Monate aufgetreten.
Und er erwähnte, dass er zwei Etagen hoch ging, die Brustschmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten.
Und die Schmerzen sind attackenartig und dauern ca. 10 Minuten.
Und die Schmerzen verstärken beim Hinlegen.
Und während sie sich sitzen oder im Hohen besen.
Bei der Vegetative Anamnese ergaben sich eine schmerzbedingte Schlafstörung und eine unnachrisch schlechte Laune.
Sie ist wegen der Beschwerden unruhig oder schlechte Laune.
Als Vorerkrankung an Amnese leitet er ca. 10 Jahre Arteriellhypertonie.
Bei der Voroperation an Amnese ergaben sich Zustände nach Transylektomie mit dem 6. Lebensjahr.
Und eine Appendektomie mit dem 18. Lebensjahr.
Beide waren komplikationlos.
Sie hat eine bekannte Nikeralergie.
Bei der Exposition reagiert er mit einem roten Ausschlag.
Er ist vorgeimpft.
Bei der Medikamentanamnese ergaben sich die Einnahmen von Nebibolol 5 mg einmal morgen.
So wie Wasserkorb 80 mg einmal morgen.
Bei der Noxen Anamnese erwähnte sie seit 35 Jahren täglich 3 oder 4 Zigaretten am Nachmittag.
Und der Drogenkonsum wurde selten verleint.
Die Noxen Anamnese ergab einen Myokasinfarkt beim Vater.
Der Vater ist über 80 Jahre alt und hat einen Bypass vor Gesicht.
Bei der Mutter ist sie auch über 80.
Sie ist ein Kind der sozialen Anamnese.
Sie ist eine Lehrerin.
Sie hat eine Tochter und leidet unter Arbeitsstress.
Aufgrund der Noxen Anamnese habe ich einen Verdacht auf Akut-Koronare-Syndrom.
Was könnte es noch Differenzialdiagnostisch sein?
Differenzialdiagnostisch kommen eine Gastroesophageal Reflexkrankheit und noch eine Gastroesophageal Reflexkrankheit.
Sonst fällt Ihnen nichts weiter ein?
Wie bitte?
Haben Sie noch eine andere Idee für eine Differenzialdiagnose?
Was noch für eine Differenzialdiagnose?
Pinomoni oder?
Zum Beispiel, ja oder?
Hier kamen gerade interessante Ideen.
Weil die Schmerzen plötzlich gekommen sind.
Der Pneumothorax war hier noch erwähnt.
Und ich meine, was man auch nicht ausschließen kann, wäre die Lungenembolie.
Das hätten die Laborwerte dann jetzt ergeben.
Und jetzt kam hier gerade noch ein interessanter Aspekt.
Ist natürlich relativ selten, aber ist natürlich eine hochkomplizierte Angelegenheit.
Erorken-Dissektion.
Wenn damit einmal so.
Ja, natürlich mal sein.
Was machen Sie denn jetzt diagnostisch?
Sie haben den Patienten ja schon notfallmäßig voruntersucht.
Was machen Sie denn jetzt noch weiter mit den Patienten?
Nach der EKG.
Ich werde zuerst körperlich untersuchen, durchführen.
Worauf achten Sie denn bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung, bei der Inspektion erwarte ich keine Auffälligkeit.
Aber bei der Oskiltation kann ich Lungengeräusche bewerten.
Und ja natürlich Herzstimmen.
Herzgeräusche.
Ja, aber was können Sie denn noch mit Ihren Augen überprüfen?
Allein vom Aspekt her.
Ja, bei der Augenprüfung ja Hautveränderung und Cyanose oder Blässe.
Man kann einfach bewerten.
Und wenn der Patient liegt und seine Schuhe aus hat und die Hosenbeine hoch macht, was können Sie noch sehen?
Atemstörung.
Dicke Beine können Sie noch sehen, ob der geschwollene Situation hat.
Kann man nachher auch tasten, aber kann man ja auch schon sehen.
Gut, was machen Sie weiter mit den Patienten?
Im Labor werde ich Herzensüme bewerten.
Ich kreiere Kinesen und Tropon E und Tropon D.
Natürlich Leba und Nierenwerte und Wildwege und Anämie.
Und ja, CAP.
Ja, also sehr klar.
Lipidprofil und Cholestasprofil werden wir bewerten.
Dann eine Eko-Kardiographie.
Gegebenenfalls eine Notfallangiographie.
Okay, ja.
Nach der Kardiographie.
Man kann das anfordern.
Gut, und auf den Blick, was machen wir noch?
Ja, wenn sich Ihre Diagnose bestätigt, also akutes Coronasyndrom, was wäre das Vorgehen?
Ja, das ist unser Protokoll.
Mornabh sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen.
Dann werde ich auf jeden Fall die Patientensituation intensiv aufnehmen.
Ab die Patientensituation aufnehmen, ja.
Die erste Maßnahme ist, in der ersten Stelle steht ein Morphin, 3 oder 5 mg IV für die Analyse.
Und Sauerstoff.
Die Sauerstoffsetzung ist unter 92.
Und einen Beta-Block.
Und natürlich Aspirin, 5-Ass Acetyl-Sylico-Orel.
Und 500 oder 600 mg sofort.
Wenn eine Notfall-Coronare-intensiv-Bewertung benötigt ist,
dann sollte man natürlich einen Chlopidogrel, 500 mg, zusätzlich geben.
Gut, dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden, was Ihre Ergebnisse bringen.
Und wenn der Patient dann auf der Station liegt, dann schauen wir nachher noch mal zusammen nach ihm.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Wir haben eine schöne Analyse gehört.
Ja, würde ich sagen, das war sehr schön.
Sie haben konsequent Ihre Fragen gestellt.
Was mir nicht so gut gefallen hat, dass Sie grammatikalisch tatsächlich sehr, sehr häufig die Satzstellung falsch machen.
Das ist also eigentlich durchgehend.
Dann, ich werde ein EKG machen.
Dann, ich habe mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Nee, ich bin mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Ja, gut.
Aber dieses dann, ich werde, das machen Sie ziemlich, ziemlich oft, dass Sie praktisch das Verb nicht an zweite Stelle setzen.
Und man hört es einfach.
Also ich reagiere da total drauf.
Ich mache das sofort.
Und das ist zwar ein Fehler, den ganz viele machen, aber man kann das vermeiden oder man kann sich das abgewöhnen ein bisschen.
Gut.
Also, Fragenkatalog fand ich eigentlich sehr schön.
Sie haben sich konsequent durchgefragt, was ich ein bisschen schwierig fand, dass Sie also, ja, gesagt haben,
ich kriege das gar nicht mehr ganz hin, zur Familienanamnese.
Sie haben also immer so ein bisschen Überschriften gesetzt.
Jetzt, aber nicht, Sie haben da eigentlich schön, da haben Sie eine gute Überleitung gemacht.
Und nachher im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch, da war das eher so ein bisschen ruckhaft, dass Sie dann gesagt haben,
ja, Familienanamnese, der Vater hat, ja, so.
Da finde ich das immer ganz schön, wenn man tatsächlich einen verbindenden Satz macht.
In der Familienanamnese ergab sich, dass der Vater mit 80 Jahren einen Herzinfarkt hatte und die Mutter so.
Was mir signifizierend aufgefallen ist, dass Sie diese Entwicklung, warum der überhaupt gekommen ist,
wie die Schmerzen heute entstanden sind, das haben Sie eigentlich nicht korrekt wiedergegeben.
Der Patient hat angegeben, dass er früher schon mal bei Belastung das kennt, dass er immer diese Schmerzen bekommt.
Wenn er also sich anstrengt, wenn er seine schwere Schultasche zwei Treppen hoch tragen muss,
dann merkt er, oh, jetzt drückt es auf der Brust.
Aber heute war das ja anders.
Heute, und das hat ihn ja Angst gemacht, heute hat er aus der Ruhe heraus mit einmal diese krassen Schmerzen gehabt
und sie waren auch so stark. Und das hat ihm Angst gemacht.
Also es war nicht so wie sonst wie die letzten Monate, sondern es war eben sehr viel heftiger und ohne erkennbaren Anlass.
Das hat ihm die Angst gemacht. Und er hatte ja auch richtige Nebensymptome wie diese Kaltschweißigkeit, Todesangst.
Das haben Sie auch ganz gut beschrieben.
Was mich gewundert hat, Sie haben gesagt Hinterbrustschmerzen.
Liebe Güte, das sind doch retro-sternale Schmerzen. Hinterbrustbein.
Also der Begriff muss wirklich kommen. Da kommen Sie nicht dran vorbei.
Das muss einfach kommen.
Dann war auch beim Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch.
Ja, wie gesagt, da schwimmen Sie deutlich mehr, wenn Sie die Story erzählen müssen.
Das war nicht so gut.
Da sind Sie auch mit Sie und er immer mal ins Schlingern gekommen.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, Patient ist so alt, ist 1,77 groß und 79 Kilo wiegt.
Und wiegt 79 Kilo.
Wieder das Thema mit der Satzstellung.
Wicht.
Gut.
Dann haben wir aber im Weiteren eigentlich nicht viele Probleme gehabt.
Ja, bei den Differenzialdiagnosen. Da waren Sie ein bisschen sparsam.
Das ist halt ein alter Düsseldorfer Fall. Da wird immer die Lungenemolie mit angegeben.
Da wird immer der Pneumotorax mit angegeben und wird immer die Erortendissektion mit angegeben.
Und Angina Pectoris.
Ich denke immer so an Angina Pectoris, das ist eigentlich auch so relativ naheliegend,
weil es dem jetzt ja schon wieder gut geht.
Könnte eben auch sein, dass der immer diese kleinen Attacken hat.
Und ja, also sollte man zumindest der Vollständigkeit halt erwähnen.
Und was ich natürlich super fand, das war Gold richtig, dass sie gleich,
als der Patient seine Probleme geschildert hat, dass sie gleich unterbrochen haben und gesagt haben,
oh ja, notfallmäßig müssen wir jetzt mal eben EKG machen und schlauerweise auch Blut abnehmen,
weil die Troponinbestimmung immer ein bisschen dauert.
Das fand ich richtig gut.
Und das ist natürlich jetzt wieder unsere sehr besondere Situation,
dass sie in Wirklichkeit dann ja wüssten, wie das EKG aussieht und wie dramatisch das ist.
Nachdem sie das geschrieben haben.
Das haben wir jetzt halt nicht zur Verfügung, aber das ist sicherlich für die Simulation,
haben sie das so sehr, sehr gut gelöst.
Ja, wie gesagt, eigentlich sprechen sie sehr gut Deutsch.
Und haben sie auch eine sehr gute Aussprache.
Diese kleine Winzigkeit, dass sie die Satzstellung immer wieder verkehrt machen, das ist schade.
Damit legen sie sich selber eigentlich so die Karten.
Das ist ja nicht grundlegend unverständlich oder so.
Nur wenn ich jetzt also tatsächlich sehr exakt bin und wenn ich sage,
ich möchte aber, dass mein Prüfling wirklich korrekt spricht,
dann sollte das ein bisschen flüssiger in diese Richtung kommen,
dass sie wirklich konsequent die Satzstellung richtig machen.
Ja, das ist mein größtes Problem.
Ja, es ist ein größtes Problem.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass ihnen das jetzt großen Schaden macht.
Aber einfach um ernst genommen zu werden, um irgendwann mal dahin zu kommen,
dass sie komplett richtig gut Deutsch sprechen,
wäre das was, an dem man noch so ein bisschen basteln kann.
Aber ansonsten, wie gesagt, Aussprache finde ich sehr, sehr gut.
Ja, vielleicht fällt mir das deswegen so besonders auf,
weil sie eigentlich sehr gut formulieren und eigentlich sehr gute Aussprache haben.
Fällt es besonders auf, dass sie diese Satzstellung nicht richtig machen.
Schade drum.
Gut.
Ja, okay.
Ja, also ich denke mal schon, dass wir mit den Patienten
uns auf der richtigen Schiene bewegt haben.
Das war alles in Ordnung.
Fand ich übrigens auch sehr nett, dass sie den immer wieder
mit Namen angesprochen haben.
Auch das, finde ich, kommt gut.
Und auch so dieser Blickkontakt in die Kamera.
Sie haben nicht die ganze Zeit vor ihrem Zettel gesessen
oder so weggeguckt, sondern sie haben eben auch Blickkontakt gehabt.
Das finde ich eigentlich auch immer sehr wichtig.
Das finde ich in der Originalprüfung sehr viel einfacher,
wenn Sie da einen Gegenüber haben.
Wir können immer nur mit unseren Simulationen,
ja, wir sind nur so eine kleine Krücke.
Wir können immer nur einen Teil der Realität abbilden,
aber immerhin ein bisschen.
Ja.
Gut, ja, vielen Dank.
Für Sie vielen Dank für die vielen mitarbeitenden,
mitfragenden und mitdenkenden Kolleginnen und Kollegen.
Wie immer eine große Freude.
Ich wünsche Ihnen allen einen schönen Abend heute.
Erinnere noch mal dran, Donnerstag bin ich nicht da.
Ja, okay.
Ah, und ich melde mich,
wann ist in der kommenden Woche, in den kommenden 14 Tagen,
wann es gehen wird.
Und dann schauen wir, ich habe ein paar Fälle im Gepäck.
Ja?
Ihnen alles Gute und Ihnen allen für heute einen schönen,
lauen, sommerlichen Sommerabend.
Lassen Sie es gut gehen. Tschüss.
Vielen Dank.
Ciao.
Herr Kollege,
können Sie bitte unsere Formel in der WhatsApp-Gruppe
unsere Formel in der WhatsApp-Gruppe,
können Sie bitte einführen?
Ja, natürlich.
Herr Kollege, ich mache das sofort ein.